Jean du Québec Jean-Paul II a été le
premier pape à visiter le Canada un
séjour de 11 jours en septembre 1984 au
Québec les foules se ruent pour le voir
et l'entendre célébrer une messe au parc
Jarry plus de 60 000 jeunes
s'agglutinent dans le stade olympique
[Musique]
Jean-Paul II est revenu ensuite deux
autres fois au pays pour rencontrer les
autochtones dans les Territoires du
Nord-Ouest et à Toronto pour les
Journées Mondiales de la Jeunesse
après les excuses officielles envers les
peuples autochtones au Vatican vendredi
le pape François annonce qu'il voyagea
ou pays on ignore à quel moment mais
tout porte à croire que l'été prochain
serait propice c'est certain il fait un
voyage passera il va y avoir des messes
publiques c'est certain c'est certain
qu'il va aller à
Marival ils vont aller dans l'Ouest si
on peut en être convaincus un voyage
complexe Sword surveillance quelques
jours avant l'arrivée du pape Jean-Paul
II à Montréal une bombe a explosé à la
gare centrale visant à annuler la visite
du chef de l’église sans compter la
tentative d'assassinat en 1981 à la
place Saint-Pierre c'est certain qu'il y
en a certains qui qui l'accueilleront
pas à bras ouverts la JRC est
responsable de sa sécurité dont les
coûts sont gardés secrets on a qu'à
penser au répercussions que ça pourrait
avoir à travers le monde s'il y avait
bavure en sol canadien au sujet de la
sécurité du pape donc il est certain que
le Canada ne l'usinera pas en cicatrait
à la sécurité le défi sera de respecter
la volonté du souverain pontife dans un
contexte d'excuses au peuple autochtones
pour les mauvais traitements perpétrés
par des membres de l’église catholique
évidemment dans un contexte qui va être
chargé d'émotions c'est un papier proche
des du peuple mais en même temps ça crée
pour les services de garde du corps
rapprochées un défi de taille mais le
plus grand défi de ce voyage sera pour
le pape François de transformer la
souffrance vécue par les autochtones
entero fertile à la guérison
ici Marie-José paquet de Comores au
Canada Montréal